The New York Police Department over the
last 12 years has made extraordinary
progress in reducing crime in New York.
Started 20 slash 25 years ago.
I'm an idea that a called compstat,
which was the idea that,
um,
turn all the data that we have about
crime transparent,
let us see in infinite detail where it's
happening,
who's doing it,
um,
gives us the opportunity to then manage
a crime control very precisely and very
and very effectively and move our
resources where crime was and in fact
bring it down in extraordinary ways.
But what we also saw was that over these
last 12 years,
the move to crime control costs than New
York police department,
citizen support.
It costs the New York Police Department,
um,
uh,
the support of citizens for an
incredibly important mission,
which was crime control.
We know that it's possible to have a
great crime control and strong citizens
support and we know that it's possible
as well to truly engage police officers
in that work.
When you have those three things moving
together and when you keep your eye not
only on citizens support and workforce
engagement and crime control,
but finally then on outcomes for
neighborhoods,
um,
and we see we measure our success by
whether people are playing in parks
where their kids can walk to school
safely,
then we'll have a success in a way that
we've never had before.
We've lost,
um,
a,
a large segment of New Yorkers,
um,
we know that we can get them back and we
need to and we need to,
in order to do that,
um,
will be successful with crime control
when we are able to mobilize all
segments of New York and support of it.
If we can't,
then we're not going to have the
information that we need.
We're not going to have the support that
we need.
We're,
today's witness will,
uh,
won't come forward tomorrow if they
don't see the results.
Uh,
so they,
we're in a new world today where,
um,
some of the traditional tools of law
enforcement have been taken away from
the New York Police Department by the
courts.
Um,
stop and Frisk.
We see the effect on the street corners
and public housing.
Trespass laws have been a very effective
tool for law enforcement because we
don't need to ask permission.
We are the,
we are the,
the agents of the public housing.
We can,
uh,
we use trespass,
summonses for that kind of control.
Even marijuana stops have been a way of
control.
Um,
those three important control tools are
now changing for the New York Police
Department and we have to find new ways
to assure safety and security for
citizens to do that we will need to
engage and to do that,
we will need to understand far better
than we do the sources of citizens
support and to see far better than we
ever have before.
Crime as it as it,
as it begins to emerge.
We know now that some of the hardest
press a precincts and boroughs of New
York,
that cruise small groups of kids,
teenagers have come together.
One hundreds of crews that are
responsible for a great deal of the gun
violence in New York by hearing them
speak,
watching them speak.
I'm looking at them on social media.
We understand who is doing a lot of the,
uh,
who's causing a lot of the damage in the
city and we've been able to address that
not by hammering entire communities but
by precision targeting,
uh,
these young people,
not all of whom were bad boys and bad
girls.
A lot of them are good kids.
I'm just getting mixed up with bad
stuff.
Um,
and instead of hammering whole
communities begin to work very
surgically,
that's the future of policing in New
York in its future.
That's data driven,
um,
that looks for the supportive
communities by,
uh,
by building up,
um,
uh,
our contact and our engagement by social
media,
by using social media also to understand
the ebb and flow of crime and disorder
and communities using it appropriately
and safely.
Um,
this is the new wave of policing in New
York is the next generation where we
measure our success now simply by
Compstat,
crime control numbers,
but by crime control,
plus citizen support,
plus workforce engagement plus
neighborhood outcomes.
And we're now able to measure all of
those in ways that we never have before.
And we planned to so that we,
as we achieve crime control,
we lift support and we lived in a
workforce engagement and we achieve
great results for neighborhoods.
That's really our goal.
And I think what we can do next.